well over the weekend thousands of trump
supporters rallied in washington d.c
they were there
in the city for much of the day
thousands upon thousands of
right-wingers trump supporters
the dreaded proud boys were in
attendance as well i'm sure there were
even some q anon proponents on the scene
i'm assuming
the point is all of the great villains
of society according to the media all of
the most brutal and extreme people
according to the media
the people who are somehow responsible
for the violence and rioting that
happens at left-wing protests
according to the media and yet all day
these groups marched rallied
conveyed their message and there was no
violence no anarchy no crime nothing was
burned
no businesses looted imagine that but
here's the where the coincidence gets
really crazy
the violence started as soon as blm and
antifa showed up
it's almost like the left brings
violence with it everywhere it goes
sorry not almost like that that is the
case
rioting looting chaos political violence
this is all nearly 100
of the time a tool of the left
exclusively
now you aren't going to see uh some of
this footage in the mass media
if that's where you get most of your
news uh so let's play some of it here
i can't play it all so it's really a
matter of choosing which documented
instances of evil leftist insanity
we're gonna focus on right now uh we'll
start with this here we have blm
and antifa harassing a group of trump
supporters who were eating
dinner after the rally and you'll see
them chucking random projectiles at the
diners
and then they move on to fireworks let's
see what that looks like
[Music]
now it seems to me that throwing
fireworks is attempted murder
now you could kill someone doing that or
at least seriously main them maim them
if we have law and order in this country
i mean actual law and order instead of
just
shows called law and order and tweets
that say law and order in all caps
uh the people who did that would have
been hauled away in cuffs and would
right now be facing
20 years in prison that's the kind of
thing if you do it
your life should be ruined we need
life-ruining consequences for people who
assault and attack innocent bystanders
people who engage in political violence
otherwise known as terrorism but instead
these low-life dirt bags are allowed to
go home after their terrorism spree
play some video games eat the lunchables
their moms stocked in the fridge
sleep in go out the next night do it all
again
the difference between revolutionaries
of the past and these
so-called revolutionaries is that the
latter first of all have no real cause
except their own empty nihilism and
hatred of everything that's good and
true in the world and second
there are no stakes for them they risk
nothing they put nothing on the line
they have no skin in the game
because nobody's holding them
accountable now in this next
piece of footage we have a girl being
accosted as she tries to escape
to safety trying to get through the
crowd she's trembling and crying
while her leftist harassers pursuer
watch this and let me know
if you can tell who the bad guys are
here is the bad guy
good guy divide hard to discern in this
situation is there any gray area here
you tell me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no you know it's pretty clear when
you're screaming at a sobbing woman
as she tries to get away from you you're
the bad guy
that's a pretty safe rule of thumb
something you can take with you in
everyday life
if you ever find yourself screaming and
cussing at a trembling woman as she
clings to a man and tries to get away
from you
there is a very very very good chance
that you are a horrible scumbag
also another tip you might consider the
possibility that you're a scumbag if you
ever find yourself pushing an old man
off his bike and pouring water on him as
happened here
or you know if you're harassing an
elderly couple because you don't like
their politics
[Music]
didn't grab you got the all right here
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
this again is one-sided okay the
dividing line between right and wrong
and our current culture war is perhaps
clearer now than it's ever been
only one side loots and riots only one
side harasses the elderly only one side
rips down statues
almost all the political violence is on
one side and that also happens to be the
side that believes in killing babies and
injecting hormones into children this is
not a dispute between
simply competing political viewpoints
this is not a mere battle of ideas
this is good versus evil nothing less
than that
and let's not ever forget that point and
this brings us to something else another
important point
many conservatives have pointed out that
democrats say they want unity even while
doing everything we just saw in those
clips
it's clear they don't really want unity
and it's important to make that
observation yes
but to be fair and also to be clear i
don't want unity either
i don't want to unite with people who
who harass and assault the elderly i
don't want to
unite with blm or anyone who supports it
i don't want unity with antifa even if
it was possible which it isn't
i don't desire unity with infanticidal
maniacs
or child abusing scumbags they don't
want unity with me
and that's fine because i don't want it
with them let's not act like our
feelings are heard
because they don't want to be our
friends and that's how it comes across
sometimes
when we say oh you don't really want
unity why won't you be our friends i
don't want to be their friends
speaking for myself that's that's just
not the dynamic here
they're screaming fu at me and all of us
and my response is
right back at you so where does that
leave us
if the divisions are are so deep that
the people on either side of it don't
even
want to bridge the gap even in theory
how can we go on how can we have a
functioning society a real country how
can we be
a people rather than just people
the answer is obvious but nobody wants
to admit it or say it out loud and it's
this
we can't we can't be a real country
we can't be a people we can't function
together as a whole
not like this in order for that to
happen
one side or the other would have to
surrender would have to give up what
defines it would have to stop
being what the other side despises short
of that the differences are as divorce
attorneys say irreconcilable
is that then where we're headed to a to
a national divorce of sorts
no i don't know part of me thinks that's
inevitable
the other part of me thinks we don't
have it in us that we'll be fine to just
coast along like this as a shell of a
country hating each other but living
together for convenience like bill and
hillary
perhaps the the internet and streaming
and video games all enable us to
retreat into virtual worlds and false
realities so that the untenable nature
of our actual reality
continues to seem somewhat tenable maybe
that's where this goes
namely nowhere in circles
i'm not sure what the distant distant
future holds but
as for the near future what i will say
is this
um these blm and antifa militants
you know what they really want to do is
they want to punish conservatives for
voting for trump the goal is to make
sure that
we never have the audacity to vote for a
big scary bully like trump ever again
but the the dirty little secret is that
trump
is not a big scary bully he never was
and so i hope that in 2024
we actually go and find that guy
go find the big scary bully go find the
guy who is what the left thinks
trump is and elect him the real deal
i already know what his campaign slogan
should be let's give them something to
cry about
i'd vote for that guy might seem a tad
aggressive but the point is
i don't intend to give one inch to these
people i don't intend to concede one
point
there will not be unity i know that and
so there's nothing to be gained from
making concessions
all we can do now is charge ahead and
let the chips fall
where they may hey you uh yeah
you you're right you right there hit the
subscribe button right now
do it do it right now i thank you for
your compliance
it's somewhat appreciated